I don't know her well but she's been
recommended to me by Cecilia quirements
engineering that's a subfield of
software engineering which one could
argue has completely gone out of vogue
because of the things I'm going to tell
you in a moment and I do work at the
intersection of privacy enhancing
technologies and security and software
engineering and most specifically the
work that I try to do is to ask what is
the problem that we should be solving
and do we have the technologies that say
that they are solving these things are
they really solving these things so like
these are the type of questions on a
very high level that I asked today I'm
going to take on the task of the title
of this workshop although I say beyond
differential privacy but I think the
question is not just about differential
privacy but also is there maybe
something we should be looking at beyond
privacy and specifically I'm going to
propose looking together at something
that we call protective optimization
technologies and that is a play on
acronyms privacy enhancing technologies
is what I work on there's a whole
community it's called pets right and
this is if you look at that Crenn emits
pots okay so about the talk I have a lot
to say so what I decided to do is I'm
going to shorten act one and turn it
into a prelude and I hope that if you
have issues with the prelude that you
just hang in there because I'm just
gonna go really big because I'm gonna
say the world change and I'm going to
describe a new world and then I'm gonna
be a little bit more specific and the
most interesting thing comes in Act four
so the more questions you ask here the
less likely you get to this so it's a
trade-off okay all right so let's start
with the prelude so the question of the
prelude is is privacy what is still at
stake with the new kind of systems that
we have and to kind of answer that
question I'm going to start with this
very famous sentence some people say
it's the World Economic Forum they're
articles that show that it has been used
many many times that data is a new oil
okay and data is a new oil has often
been translated in privacy communities
as data is the way in which these
companies make mint money or value
I think they extract and exploit data
and that's why we have like all of these
very very rich rich
in fact there's another interpretation
here which adds that it's mainly about
personal data or behavior of people and
that actually takes a lot of the
research community into doing research
on the data broker industry and here I
don't mean just like the companies that
we call data brokers but we can also see
Facebook and Google as the interpreters
in that sense and also looking at you
know the way in which data is useful for
making revenues through profiling and
for example targeting ads this
interpretation brings us to looking very
much at consumption of technology but it
doesn't make us look so much at
production of technology in business
terms we look at business to consumer
relationships and how they affect people
but we don't look so much at
business-to-business relationships ok ok
absolutely so basically we look at a lot
of the problems that appear on the
interfaces that we look at so we look at
things that you know people get
advertisement people experience a
decision they actually embodied like
embody experience it but there's a whole
technology infrastructure that brings
that interface to us and we don't look
at that it will become a little bit more
clear and because I'm into software
engineering I'm going to look at the
production of software ok so I'm going
to not start with data but I'm going to
start with computation and software so
when I look at production this is what I
see and now it's your turn what is going
on here who knows what's going on here
okay people that answer quickest are the
oldest in the room okay maybe not but
it's a good way to be thinking a page
alright so basically this is the era of
what is called shrink wrap software and
the reason it's called shrink wrap
software is that when you develop it and
have a release party so this is a
release party Windows 95 I think starts
around 92 and it actually releases 95
you put that software in on diskettes
depending on your age on CD ROMs or on
DVDs and then you put it in a box and
then you put a shrink wrap around it
that shrink wrap seems on like kind of
trivial but in fact when you break the
shrink wrap you enter a license
agreement with a company that sold you
the software so it's very important ok
Microsoft made a lot of money from the
licensing of its software from the sale
of its software however those days are
gone like Windows as a project has been
killed
Microsoft is no longer a software
company it's a cloud company and that
happened because in the last 20 years we
went through these three transitions and
many others but these are the three I
will be focusing on one is from the Box
software that you've released and you
can't change any more so easily unless
you release again two services which
means that the codebase remains with
your developers right and that's really
exciting because now you can develop
software incrementally instead of
working on it for two three years you
can have a Minimum Viable Product you
can put out a feature and then depending
on the interactions of the users you can
develop new features and because it's
services you don't develop everything
monolith monolithically you can actually
integrate third-party services you can
do one thing really well and take
everything else from everywhere else
ok and it's really efficient that turns
out to do this on the cloud but I mean
basically what the movement that is
going on here is and instead of people
installing software on their devices
after they open the box you now can just
basically get services from the cloud I
can talk about this for hours but
because we have a day to finish I'm
going to say that this thing that looks
like a trivial move in software
engineering which had immense benefits
for software companies
it used to be 70%
software projects failed and with agile
and the move to services that number is
reduced maintenance costs are reduced
and a lot more money is made and a lot
more flexibility is produced and a whole
ecosystem is produced right like we have
the service ecosystem and data plays
here an important role right so no
longer are these software companies just
looking at data as something they would
give to advertisers let's say this is a
software ecosystem in many form these
would be the advertisers but they also
use the data to continues to get
feedback on the features they develop to
get feedback on the services they
integrated and to get feedback on the
use of computational resources and in
fact for many of the people in the
business of software where money comes
from is being able to scale your product
without increase in your computational
costs and here the clouds come in
because what what was one of the biggest
costs for software companies was
basically let's say investing a lot of
money in your IT infrastructure that
would be the computers the servers and
also your system mints we had a lot of
system and jokes when there were also
many system mints but now what you do is
you rent those services from from the
cloud so what that means for companies
is that instead of sinking money which
is called a capital expense you go into
a rent mode and operations mode so you
make operational expenses you don't need
to understand very much of this but what
is happening is that the clouds are not
just an infrastructure for computation
but they are the promise that you can
make a lot of money by taking all of the
money that would go into IT
infrastructure for every organization
and centralizing it in the hands of a
few companies right so what happened
with advertisement where we had you know
a few companies make a lot of money
because they took everybody's
advertisement budget we now have a
system which is saying I will take
everybody's IT money yeah IT budget
that's a lot of money this is the
fastest growing one of the fastest
growing most popular investment objects
so there's also like a huge financial
interest in this
data is important in all of this right
data is important in making sure you
optimize your business making sure that
you have a good overview of your
resources and that you also are having
cost benefits by using the cloud so data
is not just personal data it is the oil
that is kind of making this whole system
function it's not just a resource it's
also enabler ok what does this mean for
systems
so before services systems were kind of
static so you would make let's say this
we're a bank you would make a model of
the workflows in the bank and you would
automatically in the problems with the
information systems were seen as like
surveillance you could now know things
about the employees you can know things
about the customers what we have now is
a system that has feedback loops it is
developed incrementally so what you can
do is you can constantly optimize
features depending on how people are
using them you can optimize your
employees at the bank by looking to see
if they're bringing enough profit you
can make sure that you optimize your
business agility right so you can put
layers and layers of optimization into
the development of an organization using
IT ok so this is a huge shift so so far
with me I hope ok so what this means is
that whereas here we said there's an
issue of information so we correct the
information and all we have knowledge
and we have surveillance problems and
the response to that is to provide some
sort of privacy here here we have
systems of focusing on optimization
there not so much producing information
as much as they're constantly adapting
the institutions that they're in right
so what are the harms of these systems
and what are the ways we can protect
people from those harms so that's act 2
so the question is our information
systems and optimization systems really
different and if they're really
different are the set of harm's that
they bring along also different so if I
could define this in a very loose matter
information communication technologies
allowed us to store process communicate
and share information it had a kind of
knowledge claim like we will know things
because we
be able to organize information in a
different way and it came with the
problem of surveillance the response to
which was what is privacy with
optimization systems we have the
feedback loops so these allow us to
constantly put things under the control
of objective functions and the problems
they have is that they can capture
information about the world and provide
ways to manipulate it for extraction of
value right so I can know how the bank
employees are working how the customers
are using money and I can use that to
optimize the inputs of the bank okay so
what are some of the known and discuss
risks and harms when you take a system
that captures and manipulates the world
at scale right so this is now maybe a
new set of harm's obviously if you have
a lot of data about a lot of places and
this is not just personal data right
you're collecting also information about
environment and and things like that you
have an intense amount of concentration
of power if your power if you've
actually been successful social sorting
is the term that kind of relates to
fairness it's basically saying you're
optimized for certain populations and
some populations are not very optimal so
you sort them out then there is mass
manipulation I mean we all heard about
the election manipulation so Facebook's
basically engagement platform was used
to center around fake news and was seen
to be manipulating elections at least a
majority the dominance minority erasure
and I'm pretty sure the list will go on
as we start to understand what these
systems are causing in terms of parts so
when I ask the question are they
specific to optimization systems is this
really a different beast it's maybe
interesting and provocative to say even
if you address privacy all of these
things would still occur so to be even
more provocative if all of the machine
learning and all of these systems we're
done with differential privacy you would
still have these harms and this leads me
to say that not only are the product is
the production condition and very
different than information communication
systems but the set of harms are also
distinct from privacy as we know it we
can have a longer discussion as of
whether these are infringement on
privacy autonomy if that's the right
thing I don't know
that's an open question so now I want to
go to the next step where I want to say
well what can we do with computer
scientists because this is so far was
very high level so to make my point I'm
going to look at location services which
optimize transportation in different
ways like how do we get from A to B
Google Maps ways or many other companies
out there and the first give you a sense
of the way in which we said optimization
systems capture and manipulate
environments I want to just you know
take a moment to look at some of the
favorite games of some people maybe it's
already out of vogue Pokemon go it makes
very clear the way in which these
systems not only gather information but
they can bring crowds together they can
create geography as almost right that
can be used to extract value so you have
the power to manipulate the environment
and people in that environment to cause
an event that's what Pokemon go is able
to do Waze is another example I don't
think I need to give the details because
earlier this week we talked about it
quite a bit it's a crowd crowdsource
traffic meeting app which you know makes
money by optimizing also for the users
the abilities to get from A to B now one
could say what could be wrong with this
but in fact scholars in Berkeley lucky
enough the study and showed that
actually while Waze optimizes for the
individual users in in the total of the
whole thing they make congestion worse
for everyone okay and you know so some
very basic logic to this I can share the
article with you if you're interested
whereas you know freeways and highways
decongest they're very much optimized
for D congestion so if there's a
congestion and the blockage is removed
it decongest very easily if you go to
service roads and you have congestion
it's very difficult for that congestion
to decongest
okay and so here we have a system one
could argue that has a social goal or
objective function which could be maybe
relevant to all the discussions about is
this a good AI or good machine learning
project versus bad machine learning
project so one of the things that these
systems do is optimize for a bad
objective okay but it doesn't stop there
it keeps on going so
as we know ways will route users to the
surface roads and this has an impact on
on non users and and environments right
here's the case of a road in LA which is
rather steep a lot of cars get diverted
into this and they don't come out
apparently but also the same traffic
engineer has showed that if only a few
users use Waze they benefit but if
everybody starts using Waze there's
actually anarchy right traffic energies
I think what they're calling it so they
also often tend to benefit a few okay so
what I'm trying to show you these
examples is to say maybe we can use the
language of optimization to come up with
externalities that we can then address
using computational abilities so here's
my first list so we said Waze is for
example disregarding all the non users
and the environmental impact of the
application they can benefit a few they
can do it they can have a lot of errors
right you can have this tribunal shift
you change ways for one place and then
you go to another and it causes a lot of
errors there might be decision about how
you're going to distribute your errors
there might be exploration risks and the
point is that ways of many of the
companies that do optimization is they
push the costs of all of these things on
their users on non users and on
environments so the idea would be if
that is the form in which these harms
happen is there a way to build
technologies that internalize these
costs into the company or if they don't
do that provide ways to protect the
users non users and environments yeah I
didn't expect you guys to be so quiet
okay so one could say but isn't fairness
exactly a response to this yes please
thank you yeah so use the assumption
that they're surprised of hierarchy is
that there is no
relation to this subject behavior but
it's exactly the opposite all there's
something that everyone is using ways
good ways is just about berating to
compute your best response right now so
a single person it's like helping to
find ways control system the facts on
the track together they're able to
coordinate but if they're not finding
your best response then I'll use a
different app that will but it's not
what the assumption is saying it
sometimes that everyone's using ways the
assumption is not necessarily that
everyone is using Waze I am not sure how
you got to actually one of the problems
is it's very difficult for service
providers to control the whole
environment especially if there are
multiple service providers in an
environment and therefore it's even more
difficult for them to capture the
externalities that they might be causing
so even if ways took in to consideration
and manage sort of some of the
congestion on the surface roads by
virtue of not knowing what the other
companies are doing it has limited
information and limited ability for that
to help with the question yep well you
just said you confused me then a little
bit the defining feature that you are
concerned about that the the
centralization of an optimization
technology in which case the fact that
there are others who do the same thing
would be a good thing right but now yes
it's you could go on it but I don't
think that we have enough research to
answer this question because but I do
see that centralization is an
externality in and of itself and then
the question of multiple parties acting
at once and causing mayhem because none
one of them will take responsibility for
the combined effect is another problem
how these are related are great research
questions yeah like the role that is
playing is to sort of help people find
Nash equilibria somehow you know we know
that Nash equilibria can have
price of Anarchy so but like yes there's
a very interesting question but it's
like hard to push people to something
that's not a Nash equilibrium because if
you're after tried doing that then there
would be room for any startup that would
compute best responses right because
it's so interesting like again like I
think these are the kind of research
questions I'm trying to dig out first of
all and second of all I think maybe
there's an externality to be written
here which is that once you go into the
logic of optimization there's no logic
other than that right like this idea
that maybe we don't optimize things but
we do something else sometimes which
have greater social value than
optimizing for a company is you know
seems to be maybe something we need to
put as an externality because it
literally makes us it makes many people
to start counting numbers it's like who
benefits how much well is that little
disadvantage okay it's you know it's
optimal etc and and the question is
should we really have that kind of
thinking Trump all other kind of value
systems and reasonings I guess the issue
would be that it's sort of the market
behavior that's doing this like if we
mandated like if everyone had to use way
as some ways could start computing
things that were optimizing for social
welfare but not for you
but because you have the freedom to
choose which app to use I can't do that
if they want to keep market share
because if you start if the app starts
giving me instructions that causes me to
do something that is socially beneficial
but like it takes me like ten minutes
longer to get to work increasing so
there are many different ways in which
you can imagine addressing this problem
and there was one company that I heard
about which basically said we will not
reuse residential roads right and that
way they level the field for all the
parties and they said that because the
party the field was not level they
didn't these indeed lose out to waste so
if that's your question yes that's an
issue so then the question is how do we
address these harms in a way that is
fair - maybe market effects but also
society for you made the perfect liberal
is somehow not possible or a certain
opportunistic correlated equilibrium
probably yes correlated equilibrium is
one kind of approach to this because the
price of Anarchy can be lower for
quarterly it can mean that should be
broom fun there are some songs
that's right system of stability isn't
one either so but yes if you can define
more precisely what's wrong with
optimization is it about who is doing it
how is it different from the way I mean
really governments also trying to the
government was used right and it's a
question in that is what makes this a
special case is that we optimize by a
different method
collecting information the
infrastructure of production that you
have disappeared we need to work people
for uses about the optimization because
the optimization may be you know if it's
done by corporations maybe they maximize
profit right don't take into account you
know maybe we'll force them to take into
account well force everyone to use
weights
we'll have zero competition that make
the optimization optimal right so I
think so the market question I hadn't
considered before so this is very useful
already but the point that we're making
here is that there's a higher level
question of is this a good goal or not
but these costs incurred regardless of
whether the goal is good or not right so
you can have an optimization system
which has an objective objective
function where you say this is great
definition of social welfare we should
do that it doesn't keep you from having
errors it doesn't have to keep you from
having exploration risks and the
question is who will take care of those
costs and what we know for example from
Waze is that individuals communities
neighborhoods municipalities have
contacted ways and gotten no answer
right and so there's a governance issue
here so they do not responds there's a
governance issue also that there's no
local liability maybe so like there's
all these like bigger questions that you
guys work on but there's also the
question of like how do we even notice
the errors in the costs and how to them
which is that information you know I
don't think the point is that we should
outlaw optimization I don't think that's
where I'm going
although I think there are people for
example if you look at the discussion
around facial recognition there are
people who are saying this kind of
optimization is not acceptable so there
might be that question at some point but
I think in this case in the ways case
traffic I mean I'm saying today that
they're causing mayhem by introducing
surface road traffic but if you look at
like the introduction of freeways and
highways they were
absolutely like reprimanded and said
like they're awful and they're
destroying neighborhoods and
what-have-you
so I think it what I'm trying to do here
is actually say this is a very political
decision that these optimization
companies are making they're using
public infrastructure as often they're
piggybacking on them and yet they're not
deliberating at all what are the values
were object like optimizing for yep we
add them and then in some sense you know
it's not like optimization of the new
thing right right yeah so why why is it
that you feel that this is a
qualitatively different phenomenon now
hmm it was 30 years ago pre like white
use of the internet right sure I mean
they I guess I mean you know arguably
like any kind of bad equilibrium outcome
and game you know mm-hmm like in a
market or whatever is it is like a
result of people you know this kind of
exhibits like oh you know all they've
all of these problems right yep so yeah
so that's my quote like what is it that
you think of as the key difference I can
think of a few of it you want to think
with me like if you have some idea that
act like one one big one is that we're
all using the same optimization software
mm-hmm okay right and so we're using the
same information to optimize as opposed
to like you know back when we had paper
maps and we were all optimizing using
kind of whatever crappy information was
on the radio and like just wasn't that
good and so we were kind of like mm-hmm
in some sense had some randomization in
our
so I think there's like two things I
will say and I'm just you know
intuitively saying these things it's not
like I have thought about them as much
in death that's why I'm giving this talk
the first one is we can make the same
argument for privacy like we you know we
had privacy issues before there's
nothing different about them when with
the introduction of information systems
that doesn't change the fact that we
need to say there is a surveillance
problem and or there is a if you don't
want to call it a surveillance problem
but something else and we want to
respond to that so I think I'm asking
have we been looking at the harms of
machine learning and optimization in a
systematic way and in fact most of this
stuff is from AI safety literature if
you haven't noticed yet but most of it
is said to be just accidents and I'm
just wondering if we can maybe be more
responsible about these costs and do
something about them yep maybe part of
the issues and a part you're using ways
as an example there's a level of
centralized planning that is being kind
of slipped under for example we can
complain about the roads and highways
and where they
placed and all of the problems with the
process there was a process that was to
consider multiple values participation
ability in a way that I think you're
saying these systems don't because it's
a centralized planning process without
any center I think that would be another
one yes absolutely
absolutely yes that would be another one
I just wanted to also add to that that
it's not just the centralization but the
fact that almost they're going into
every sector and every activity right
like including how we communicate with
each other or whatever so that's I think
like there's a qualitative different
maybe not I want to get the pots though
right not that you know not they
proposals to outlaw optimization but
like it seems to me as a thought
experiment if nobody was using any kind
of you know optimization software many
of these problems would still exist like
a particular think about like
distribution of errors you know like the
examples people use or you know okay
I've got a drive to the hospital I
shouldn't be the person that's used to
like explore but you know you live
different populations will have sort of
different familiarity with the road
networks and traffic patterns yep so
sort of the lack of optimization will
exacerbate the sort of information
disparity the different populations have
mm-hm
so like I would have my first select
reaction would have been at something
like ways actually of course
these concerns are all there that for
many of them obviously not vast data
collection but for many of them is
ameliorating these things compared to
what would have been the case like in
the absence of
right so I think like one critique of
our work is like what is the starting
point right and I think that's one that
we're still grappling with because it
does mean like let's start like there at
T zero there was no optimization or
there were other forms of optimization
and now we added another one how do we
deal with that and I think this is
something again like it's a question how
do we model these things but maybe one
of the important points I'm trying to
make is that it is not sufficient to
just look at the machine to address some
of these issues but we have to look at
the environments that we're in and I
don't know that we're equipped right now
to have the way to model and look at
those things and understand the kind of
Delta between you know environment
without an environment with the system
and how do we evaluate that difference
okay Noah Pollak knows like should I go
on because like I'm just looking at the
time should I continue it's yeah okay so
one could argue that fairness deals with
these issues and and I think this might
maybe help with trying to see what the
difference is between the optimization
harms and fairness first of all fairness
is not the only externality although of
course like as soon as you talk about
risks and costs are not equally
distributed across society so the more
costs that you externalize the more
likely you're going to hit certain
populations more than others but what is
also interesting about a lot of the work
in the fairness framework is that you
assume a trusted service provider so we
assume that the service provider has
incentives to recognize and remedy
fairness issues and as somebody coming
from the pet community the first thing
we do is say what happens to the world
if we if this assumption is not true and
that's what we do in our parts work the
other thing that I think this community
might have something to say about is
that not only may not have they may not
have the incentives but they might also
not have the means so if they're so to
save multiple optimization companies
working in an environment they might be
causing something that none of them can
readily be able to foresee or be able to
do something about and the important
thing about the difference again is the
D contextualization whereas fairness
will look to see to make sure that there
are equal outcomes for everyone in
different
forms or fair outcomes for everyone they
often abstract away the actual goal of
the system and what we try to do here is
to say okay if the goal of the system is
not okay then making it fair is not
going to be good either so we try to
kind of compensate for that issue that
arises in some of the parents were
frameworks okay so what is our
proposition given the what we have
learned from the difference of fairness
and optimization harms so this is where
we enter pots and pots are very much
informed by people doing things to
respond to optimization systems so one
of the things people will do in their
neighborhoods is report that there are
blockages on their streets or make you
know there's also a grouping of
researchers who made it look like there
is a traffic jam on the freeway by
creating a bunch of ghost accounts so
that Waze would divert all the traffic
away from the freeway and they could
have it for themselves so we see these
kind of users trying to find ways to
give let's say unsolicited feedback to
way so that they would reroute the
traffic to other roads okay so we were
kind of excited about this there are
some more examples I think I told these
two and this is like the Miami pollute
police basically M polluted the whole
Waze database so that it looked like
there were police controls everywhere
which is kind of scary but okay they did
that and if you heard Helen stock from a
couple of weeks ago this is indeed like
very close to option techniques that
have been used against unfair practices
and advertisement okay so how would B be
developing pots the idea is to basically
use our computer science skills to
systematize and make effective or ensure
that they're effective such such attempt
to reoptimize the situation for
individual groups of users or
environments in that sense pots is very
similar to adversarial a machine
learning but instead of assuming that
the adversary is the one that is
attacking the service provider we assume
the service provider is adversary that
is serving the machine learning and that
the users are the ones that need to be
protected so how would we develop a pot
you would first identify an externality
so if this is the highway and it's
the city that is basically being
constantly congested because Waze is
suggesting the surface road we would
then imagine this is just an intuition a
benefit function for all the entities
that are affected by the system so this
would include users non users and the
environments that they're moving in and
see like okay who benefits in what way
from the system I'm assuming that
benefits above this line are positive
and below it or negative for people so
that means that you know the person who
gets from A to B is benefits like happy
puppy gets for me to be very fast super
happy this is the person who flew into
somebody's garden because that road was
actually not very safe for so much
traffic and then like we would start
building a system that would look to see
how we can modify the input so that we
could get a better or more desirable
output for this it's a neighborhood by
diverting the traffic from them and if
we want to optimize we could also do
that like think about what would be the
you know fewest number of roads we would
have to block so that the traffic cannot
go through now pots can have different
goals I mean the one we produced with
the one that I just showed it could be
that you know everybody has you know the
ones who benefit a lot benefit a little
less so I think this is going to some of
your questions earlier and the ones who
have been you know lose a lot maybe
benefit more or maybe there's a way in
which you know we can have benefits more
for everyone like in the case of Pokemon
go it's like unevenly distributed but
maybe we can have more pokemons for
everyone this is the protest case it's
like there's so many ways to define a
social welfare this is the case where
you practically attack the users that
benefit the most from the system so that
they start complaining so that the
company responds this would be one way
to do this and the sabotage option is
when you basically make sure the system
is not giving any optimal results okay
how do we formalize this again we're
very much informed on some level by
software engineering theory we don't
want to just look at the algorithm but
we want to look at the system and when
we look at the system we think about
Michael Jackson not the dancer but the
software engineer theorist who said that
a system is this is going to be
complicated but
basically systems exist in environments
and we build them to fulfill
requirements in those environments right
and so we're going to think about not
just looking at the system but the world
in which it exists in as well so we
assume the optimization system has a
number of optimization algorithms and it
has some inputs and outputs on the other
hand we have agents agents could be
users non-users environments or other
optimization systems agents can take
actions so this is also really important
parts do not have to be input into the
optimization system around the bay area
I heard from Deidre that people will
draw big dark circles on their on their
road so that they can get automated cars
from not entering because it looks like
potholes but you've heard of that I
found it actually I also found an artist
that like those like salt wudu on cars
and makes it look like they're like
stripes and they can't get up anyway so
I'll show you all the stuff if you want
to know there's lots of good stuff out
there we assume that the agents and the
optimization system exist in a world and
the world is a bunch of states goes from
state to state every time somebody takes
an action the world is the place that we
kind of imagine to have information
about all the entities but of course the
identities themselves don't have all the
information so they have partial views
on an app which we call observations on
the world so the optimization system has
an observation of the world and each of
the agents have an observation of the
world and the world changes States
through basically actions of the agents
and for simplicity we assume that's one
agent at a time takes an action and then
the response that comes from the
optimization system and then we assume
that the optimization system will
optimize for its own objective functions
and we're able to build a pot that will
reoptimize
for the agents that we're basically
serving so this is our idea there are
other pots in the wild Pokemon go users
because of the disparity of availability
of pokemons will often spoof GP GPS they
will also make changes to open street
maps to make their area look like a
little river or lake or park because
they're more likely to generate poke
monson which is really crazy news for
people who build OpenStreetMaps uber
drivers will turn off their apps and
synchronously to induce search prices it
is not always clear if this is like
urban myth or reality but I think this
is something that the similar things are
happening so that every drivers tried to
you know make it better
earning we did some experiments with
credit credit scoring outcomes to see if
you can change some of the parameters of
how long and how much you take out for a
loan and spaghetti yes instead of an O
or think about a community that takes
out a lot of small loans and then repays
them to entry to generally like improve
the state of that community in the eyes
of the credit scoring agency unfit bits
was an artist project which was for
people who are required by their
workplace to wear a fitbit's and do do
exercise they had options on how you
could also change the input okay so to
conclude I define optimization systems
to be different from information systems
in the sense that they capture and
manipulate behavior and environments for
the extraction of value in the different
sections I argued that you know it
privacy in these systems is still a
problem but may be a sub problem among
many there are different beasts and they
all introduced externalities and that
even if you address them using for
example differential privacy and what is
also important I think is that we have
done a lot of work of protection in the
fairness domain assuming that the
service providers are trusted we have
seen a lot of bad behavior in the last
years especially from Facebook of you
know manipulating results and I think
like Alexandra's work here is also very
important so we need to maybe ask
questions about what kind of other
models we can develop that doesn't
solely depend on the service provider
and there are lots of research questions
some of them you raised during the
discussion so what are the problems that
are or can or cannot be solved with pots
or things that look like pots and if we
can see pots as an instance of
rethinking trust models what would be
other alternative into
maybe there's something to learn from
other fields that we don't know we have
mostly thought about pots for protection
of fundamental rights but you can
imagine in a service ecosystem that you
can you can have parties who are
integrating machine learning from other
parties that they might also want to be
able to intervene in machine learning
processes and I think in general we're
kind of asking the question you know
more and more machine learning service
providers have this idea that they want
to secure machine learning which is like
from a security perspective I see the
value of that but is there maybe some
value in the insecurity of machine
learning that we can think a little bit
about or is there way to pluralize
service providers in some way or
decision-making in some way that we
haven't thought about so far our pots
justified when and how and how can they
be formalized are some of the questions
we're grappling with and I hope we'll
get some feedback here try to be short
so that Erin can say more interesting
comments so I don't know don't know much
about software engineering but you know
I try to say a few words from more
algorithmic perspective you know so when
I first you know learn about algorithms
you know many years ago obviously you
know things ain't Rather's
yeah simple environment right you learn
how to you know sort a list of numbers
or you know we try to optimize a very
simple objective function so up to my
vision when we learn it is a very you
know simple problem just tell your
objective function optimize it but one
thing that you know that got brought up
a very interesting point your targets
you know we need to think about you know
when algorithm operate or system
operates in reality often need to
interact with in a bigger environment
with
you know many people many different
sorts of people in subsidence it could
be the users that's in using ways of the
platform it could be none users right so
it could be like people living in
different neighborhood who may not want
the traffic passing through the
neighborhood or you know it could be you
know user in a different platform it
could be you know I'm a ways user man
but you know ways might be implicitly
impacting you know users of google map
through my you know traffic route so I
think these all these factors are pretty
interesting and more generally we would
like to think about you know through
this interaction how do we you know
incorporate take into account people
societal values like privacy and
fairness or sometimes incentives right
so like I think I like the word you know
protective and in part you know and you
know from my own research I like to
think about two forms of you know
protections you know just one obvious
way you know when people design system
they would like to you know protect the
system from potential malicious behavior
from users or you know gaming behavior
like you know I just learned that you
can draw you know you know huge black
holes on on the floor so they know
although driving car will pass through
that's pretty interesting so you know
when we my system designer design is
algorithms or system they like you know
this kind of robustness in the first
place so it's somewhat like a protection
for the system and you know nowadays we
would like to also think about how to
protect people's values you know
obviously you know there is privacy and
fairness and one way we would like to
think about it as a Whitham person is to
usually think about these kind of
notions for life privacy and fairness as
some form of algorithmic constraint and
try to solve the underlying optimization
problem subjective these kind of
constraint so more interesting question
comes somehow come out right you know as
an algorithm person you know the easy
technical question would like to think
about is okay given the constraint I'm
gonna generate the output to satisfy
this or form constraint while optimizing
the objective and you know if I you know
have different form of constraint or
different slackness in the constraints
so to speak I can generate a family
a space of models that I can explore how
do we think about you know negotiating
these kind of different trade off or you
know different kind of outputs to the
actual stakeholder I think these are you
know interesting questions that go
beyond the algorithm design question
another thing I would like to think
about is you know how do we think about
you know trade of other former trade up
not just between different groups of
people you know I like you know the the
the problem thinking about you know how
do we model you know this kind of
algorithm interacting with many many
different people through an environment
so we can think about modeling this kind
of interaction and there's a interesting
trade up between you know what I think
is model complexity and also
tractability obviously you can you know
keep adding elements into your model and
make it more complicated and perhaps
more realistic and proving more and more
complicated theorems at the end of day
that even yourself cannot interpret but
at the same time you you do want to
capture some of the salient features you
know that you want to address so I think
there's also an interesting question at
least for a theory point of view how do
you know managing this kind of trailer
well you know conducting this kind of
formal study okay so I will let you know
interesting people take over the
conversation so I wonder and this came
up a little bit while you're talking but
how many of these you raise are really
questions about optimization versus
questions about equilibrium like I think
that's it to like answer a lot of the
questions you're pointing to is thinking
about incentives really has to be you
know front and center and I sort of
and that's because I should think that
the kinds of optimization algorithms
that Google has the freedom to deploy
are quite limited by incentives right
since I sort of think about these tools
as helping us to find equilibria and
maybe they can have maybe there was room
for some tweaking of the optimization in
that they can choose amongst the
equilibria and we can try to like push
ourselves towards better equilibrium but
it seems like it would be very difficult
because you know like ultimately
individual people are optimizing for
themselves when they choose what happed
to use to like have it try to implement
any optimization that doesn't lead to
equilibrium and it's like a lot of a
sort of bad things you're pointing to
are perhaps just properties of
equilibria and you know similarly like a
lot of the manipulations he talked about
are arising because there are sort of
you know like aspects of the larger game
that like are not currently in
equilibrium I can leave my ways that I'm
in my car and trick them into taking
this traffic but yeah so it's not really
a did they seem like very interesting
economic questions today yeah well
that's trying to think through why you
wouldn't use the price mechanism
if there are absolutely like I mean I
think if anything this the idea is not
to say let's say pots do not have our
technological but we imagine that
economic political and other mechanisms
shouldn't be should and be part of this
identification of the problem right like
we just kind of surfaced this problem
because for most people it's like
optimization what could go wrong and we
tried to kind of make it clear and what
didn't happen here which is interesting
is that most people say it's unethical
to do pops and then we asked them like
okay we're just optimizing too so you
don't think the companies are unethical
like why do you think it's only
unethical when we optimize so it raises
a lot of interesting right and and and
for sure I think this is like a very
very big problem
coming from the pets background so this
is kind of the world in which I
discussed it a little later a little
yesterday I have a [ __ ] chat line so
that the pets community is for example
for good or bad reasons
for libertarian and less libertarian
reasons we'll be very distrustful of the
law and the government so they will
think about technological solutions for
something that they don't expect like
the the institution has to be able to
provide protections sometimes and you
can see that definitely in human rights
context right like you can imagine when
you know some company or some or some
government starts using machine learning
to do very oppressive things that like
technological solutions might be the
only proposition instead of you know the
economic one or the political one and so
I think we're just putting technology as
a player and not suggesting that this is
the way to solve and in fact the first
paper we wrote on this was off to pots
can can the Revolution be out be
optimized and that was a question mark
great like and I think we can't solve
optimization problems with more
optimization I actually have a doubt
about whether we can do that let me just
see all the hands and okay I'll just go
like this cuz I guess I'll just come
back to the earlier question of like why
is why are these questions fundamentally
different from ones people have faced
previously I mean certainly in technical
like since the advent of the Internet
these types of things have come up a lot
like you know avoiding packet inspection
by whatever you know quality of service
types I'm blanking on the term but where
I you know give differential access to
different providers to my network or you
know even just people like hacking
supermarket like right yeah yeah so like
it seems like on one row I don't want to
take away from these or the fact that
like obviously tech had a technological
level these questions are really
different been like you know is there a
is there a way to phrase this you know
just kind of like what Aaron was asking
about like you know this is you know
there's this language of economics that
seems to fit well you're
what is the kind of what is this a
special case of I guess because you've
thought about this a lot right back with
obfuscation do you want to ask it so
that I can well it's just in the market
flip I don't know but in the market
place you always have people who say use
my product because it's gonna give you
some advantage over all those other
suckers you know so that's a way in
which we're like finance comin
how many invest your money with us
because we know how to get you a better
return on your investment then that
company so but there is something about
the cases that you described that makes
me feel like it it's more than just the
edge is something that feels I'm just
about some of these cases either I'm
just to the people who don't have it but
it's damaging to some kind of society
and of course it I'm still and I mean
link to the first part of your but I'm
just struggling with the link to the
first pub and story wait first to me
like that part of the story needs to be
sharpened maybe I don't have answers to
that
like one technical answer you could get
like Adams question is that sure the
stuffs been going on for a long time but
the centralization still makes they
giving it to you by that you know these
companies are still bound to implement
equilibria the centralization still
makes a difference right because the
price of an RP like the worst Nash
equilibrium is different than the price
of stability of arms of the best Nash
equilibrium and he said close that can
gives you the power to try to now select
well is it yeah I guess in general scale
well there's power and also the factors
like any any like imperfections in the
optimization are like replicated and
scale in a way they wouldn't have been
[Music]
there I'm saying like overall traffic
could get better if we with good
information about which highways are
congested okay can I ask something
okay this yeah yeah exactly right thank
you I just I wanted to say to you
one was I you know when when we see
right I think on what you're saying is
that there's a public or collective good
issue not yet
what toothpaste you choose might affect
what's available to the marketplace but
it doesn't affect other people the same
way your choice for to drive does right
there's like
I shared resource implications and I
think you know like how I choose to
interact with the financial markets
right like making my trades etc is both
private choices yet it's highly
regulated that we we care a lot about
kind of understanding some of the
network effects and externalities like
in that infrastructure and I think for
some of the same reasons it's not an
area where I do research but when I
think about like Nasdaq I think there's
something there that you might look at
and then the other thing I wanted to say
is for me one of the things as a you
know as a lawyer that's super
interesting in thinking about the sort
of coordination that we're used to in a
fully mediated mediated environment like
the internet and bringing them out into
physical places we know right like the
law says okay Facebook you can tell
people they have to use their real names
right then this idea about being legible
to the machine in a particular way of
presenting yourself in a particular way
and as this stuff comes out in the
physical environment these questions
about using APIs that rate the whole use
of the term adversarial suggests that
one party is the true white knight for
you in this way becomes really
interesting and and the place you know
Yoshi Qo'noS were and the red Selleck is
deface you know it is graffiti on a
traffic sign now like literally a
criminal is it interferes with the car
leaving the site it wouldn't right and I
so I think the questions of how law
interact
with these sorts of activities in
physical spaces is super interesting on
something we really need to keep our eye
on because the logic of how we've dealt
with an in technical spaces carries over
I think we have lots of really difficult
problems and subversion of public pools
and faster private goals where we have
determined public goals matter right
yeah absolutely and I think yes this is
absolutely the direction we want to go
and that's why beyond that you said
earlier is this a temporal phenomena
because it seems to me that this
conflict that you described that this
the world design streets designed
according to a logic that didn't
anticipate an optimization algorithm
maybe cities would look entirely
different if we had known there can be
something like an optimization algorithm
exactly right and so I wonder if I mean
you've thought through all of these
other examples but I wanted it if the
externalities you described and the
problem comes because this something in
the physical world designed under
different premises and in a way we
design for the presence of such
optimization on demand light timing and
things that are about using optimal the
ability to optimize but for a public
good rather than and I do think that I
think again like I'm gonna turn
everything almost that is said into
research questions because the question
is like I was very impressed by the way
like all these we said these are just
economic questions or you can these can
be predominantly addressed as economic
questions but in fact like how we run
our cities is not just an economic
question so I think there's something
about this optimization logic and I'm
not talking about everyone that you know
is so associated with extraction of
value that also maybe pulls us to a more
economic realm on things that we used to
see as social or political realms and I
think that switch is not trivial and we
need to have a discussion about what
that should look like so
that's maybe a question of like should
we be taking optimization into account
where and then when we do how right they
can those are different questions like
to try and address optimization I mean
the problem and here again I would
encourage you to whether optimization is
you know to think about this you know
it's something that might be harmful I
think it's problematic because in and
off itself there is nothing wrong to do
this is actually something that groups
you know could be socially good and so
one question is whether you know he's
doing a private to public and if it's a
governmental function we probably want
it to be informed by by public interest
rather than private right so it would be
it would make a difference in other
words whether we look at it waste that
is optimizing traffic or looking at
Pokemon so who cares whether you know I
don't know does everybody feel like that
no society would probably say class
right and I think yeah what makes this
difference an optimization here makes a
difference if we optimize our social
goals using these systems this is a
completely different way than explicitly
deliberating about our social goals so I
have really two completely this is not
an economic issue
it's a political issue whether we want
to rebuild our roads whether we want to
have more cars less cars going through
this neighborhood through that night
different political issues we need I
mean now we deliberate contest is really
interesting all these systems that
optimize it that they actually define
political Lawrence in the way they you
know they in a dynamic way and I think
that creates a challenge for law because
we know when the norm is we would say
this is a bad mom this is a good moment
but what if they don't changes I think
that we have seen the yesterday about
see that you know about the standard of
you know what is it good
what would make you a better fit right
if you have a flag whatever the way what
are the standards for a good for doing
the best you know sport or there it can
change depending on who is in the system
because this is optimizing right so here
the doors would also change on a dinner
and I think that that creates a problem
between yeah I would love to thank
everyone for all the valuable comments
especially
[Applause]